Yeah, let's deliberate.
All right, uh, so what --
what were they talking about?
[ Laughter ]
-I didn't catch any of it.
-I missed all of it.
I mean, you gotta figure
that guy -- he did it, right?
-Definitely.
-He burnt the couch.
Without a doubt.
I mean, unless we buy
the conspiracy.
Unless we buy that
someone else did it
or he set him up.
That's just ridiculous.
He said he smoked weed
on the couch.
There is a little bit
of truth to, you know,
you did invite the guy over
and get him really high,
and they guy's like,
you know,
known for doing
that kind of thing,
so in a way,
maybe, kind of...
Set him up?
...like, deserved it
a little bit,
maybe, you know?
Yeah, but he invited him
over to his house,
gave him weed to smoke.
I know.
It just all seems
very generous
considering how much they seem
to not like each other.
-Yeah.
-Exactly.
I feel like they've
hung out before, too.
He wants a whole new couch.
Wait, he wants
a brand-new couch?
That's what he wants, yeah,
and he says it cost $1,600,
but that was two years ago.
There's now way
that thing cost $1,600.
Yeah, yeah.
While I take this bong rip,
I'm gonna calculate.
-Depreciation...
-Over the year.
-Two years.
-And there is a --
There's a formula
for depreciation.
But it's Italian leather.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, we're not talking
about just a white couch.
Sometimes friendship,
you know...
We're talking about
Italian leather.
Italian leather takes
precedent over friendship.
Mm-hmm.
I get that.
-That was the greatest picture.
-Yeah, that was amazing.
I wanna give him the case
just for the picture.
[ Laughter ]